the New York Times has put together a
composite ranking of where Americans are
healthy and wealthy or where they're
struggling and let's take a look at the
graph okay so the Times came to this
conclusion by looking at six data points
for each county in the United States and
they included education median household
income unemployment rate disability rate
life expectancy and obesity alright so
where are you doing worse the more red
or the more orange it gets are the
places you're doing worth so a lot the
South not doing that well
the tiny orange dot by New York City I
don't know if you can see it over there
is the Bronx so not doing that well in
the Bronx Northern California I was
surprised not doing as well as I would
have thought now we're in SoCal over
here and we're doing okay but again the
South is by far the worst the Midwest
seems to be okay Florida I thought was
kind of interesting because the beaches
all are in good shape but if you're in
the middle of Florida you're not doing
too well is there anything the middle of
Florida will be the beaches at our ears
actually Miami by the time we finish
this show completely will be a coral
reef
tell me finish this yeah exactly so
notice right there that it's the highest
concentration of doing worse right in
the heart of the voting against our own
interest belt okay so there's a reason
Alabama went for Romney and you're
looking at it right now yeah so what's
going on in that in that orange area
Lois can you gain I'm colorblind so I
actually can't see this map well just
trust me it's not doing too well in the
south Jason no I thought that criterias
really interesting I was interested that
they included obesity in there and it
was unemployment obesity and I figured
what else was in there but it seems very
subjective I'm always think about these
things in terms of like my life cuz I'm
a selfish self-involved person so I was
just thinking that like in Los Angeles
being obese is a lot harder than I feel
like it is in in some of those blue
places in the Midwest right I'm just
saying that was my personal opinion yeah
I'm with you do you think there's a
connection between happiness and
gay marriage because apparently by that
map it looks like there's some
connection the places where gays are
okay there's something what is that I
okay I mean there's lots of states where
where marriage equality has come about
because of activism by a morally
awakened populace and other states where
a judge has just said no and whether you
like it or not so I don't I don't think
it's you mean those crazy activist
judges were always radically doing
things that are you help people you're
an activist judge if you help
corporations you're strictly but I do
think that that um in many cases yeah
you know in a more progressive place
where you have if you if the people have
brought about marriage equality the same
people have probably bought about a
higher wage less income and equality and
therefore more happiness it's why
Denmark is much happier than we are and
why the american dream really should be
called the scandinavian dream because
they enjoy much higher standard of
living of less income inequality and you
know no one goes bankrupt ever trying to
pay for health care but aren't they not
as free as us isn't that they're more
free than us I know I'm just kidding
yeah so wait let's just throw the graph
up for one or a second because there was
one that I thought was particularly
interesting there Wyoming they're pretty
happy in Wyoming there's a 17 of them so
Wyoming hopefully if you if you need to
look at a map while you're looking at
this to figure out why the middle I'd
love to see what North Dakota looks like
in five years because the fracking
economy is gonna change the entire
economic makeup of the whole state and
you can go to a place that was a one
stop sign town a year ago and make six
figures now driving a truck up there and
fracking will change the entire economy
of North Dakota right so you'll make a
lot of money through fracking but your
water might be exploding yes that could
be a press oh if your if your water
explodes in your face even if you're in
a big fancy house probably wouldn't be
too happy he would be doing worse so it
might suddenly get better and then when
the exploding water comes then it'll get
worse there's so many other factors to
factor into this in news it was a very
it's very interesting it's just I don't
think it's a complete picture yeah any
means so Wyoming that's why I think
Wyoming's the interesting one because
there are so few people there yet they
seem so is that partly at their glance
Cheney's drop out of the race NZ so
that's why happiness has gone up
then I could have Liz Cheney as their
senator